c'est un nouveau rendez vous les
vendredis à cette heure nous allons
faire la revue de la semaine politique
avec sébastien beauvais à québec
emmanuelle latraverse a town messieurs
dames
bonsoir à vous par s'est passé je vais
recommencer avec vous par ce qui a
marqué la fin de cette semaine qu'on
reviendra au début bien sûr de la
semaine avec l'élection à emmanuel mais
sur la question autochtone ces
allégations d'agressions très grave de
la part de ceux qui devaient les
protéger ces femmes de toc tonnes à
valdes à là on a vu vraiment une
réaction ce matin très vive laminé selon
réagissent le tir on ce qui va se passer
quelque chose aussi dans cette future
enquête le faut que les choses bougent
oui elles ont bougé rapidement au cours
des dernières heures je vous rappelle
parce qu'on se pose énormément de
questions sur le rôle de la sûreté du
québec en particulier euros du
gouvernement qui a 12 24 heures avant la
diffusion du reportage de l'émission
enquête
il était pas question de confier l'anc
est sûre les abus allégués de policiers
de la sûreté du québec sur des femmes
autochtones à un autre corps de police
de la sûreté du québec stella est ce qu
qui enquêtait sur des policiers de là
est ce qu il n'était pas question non
plus de retourner chez eux des huit
policiers visés par cette enquête
mais à peine douze heures après la
diffusion du reportage de l'émission
enquête
tout d'un coup tout avait revirer de
bord le paquebot et elle s'en aller dans
une autre direction
c'était le service de police de la ville
de montréal qui inquiète et 18 policiers
étaient de retour chez eux alors que
s'est il passé pourquoi les policiers
n'avaient pas les informations n'étaient
pas au courant de l'ampleur des
allégations révélées hier par l'émission
enquête comment ça se fait que depuis
cinq mois
les policiers sont au courant que le
gouvernement est au courant les
policiers n'étaient pas capables d'aller
aussi loin que les gens des missions que
nos collègues de l'émission enquête
alors ce sont toutes des questions qui
se pose est évidemment en trame de fond
y as que les policiers ont essayé de
protéger leurs propres collègues ya pas
de réponse
attention on n'a pas de réponses à ces
questions là il faut dire tellement se
poser des questions et il faut dire
sébastien
pour être tout à fait précis que
certains des témoignages entendus hier à
l'émission enquête n'était c'était la
première fois que ces femmes-là en
parlait et la journaliste dieu sait
qu'elle a travaillé un josé est très
très fort pour convaincre ces femmes-là
de publiquement dénoncé ce qui est
arrivé quelques années dans certains cas
auparavant
donc c'est peut-être une partie de
l'explication c'est ça et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que les policiers disent
c'est que ils ont appris des
informations hier dans le reportage de
l'émission enquête mais je vous relance
une autre question si ces femmes là ont
décidé de parler à la télé plutôt qu'à
la police
est-ce que c'est pas parce que il ya un
bris de lien de confiance en la femme là
et les policiers voilà et parlant de
liens de confiance et manuel bon il ya
ce projet à ottawa d'une enquête sur le
sort des femmes de toc tonnes à québec
on veut aussi faire une commission
parlementaire
expliquez-moi comment tout ça va
s'imbriquent emmanuel commun vous voyez
ce projet fédéral du nouveau
gouvernement qui va se mettre en place
d'enquêter sur ces questions c'est une
promesse de longue date il faut dire que
ce dossier des femmes autochtones
violente et agressé disparu ça fait des
années qu'ils trouvent écho d'un océan à
l'autre je voudrais mais qui fait partie
des débats ici à ottawa le gouvernement
harper a toujours fermé la porte à toute
enquête publique entend écouter ce sont
des affaires judiciaires c'est à la
police de faire son travail
bon on va pas sauver l'ironie de ces
propos là dans le contexte de ce qui se
passe à val d'or aujourd'hui mais le
parti libéral a premier qu'il y aurait
une enquête publique indépendante
rapidement de mise sur pied justement
pour faire la lumière sur l'ensemble du
dossier et on imagine toute la
complexité aux forces d'apple parce que
prenez le code valdes a imaginé la
l'ensemble du pays des cas comme ça il y
en a plein
on imagine une commission itinérante de
40 ans je veux dire comment on fait
c'est ce qu'on a dit est-ce que s'est
décidée d'après vous ce que les
sionistes ne s'est pas et
les libéraux ont certainement commence à
avoir une idée me sont en ce moment en
pleine transition c'est pas quelque
chose qui vont annoncer avant d'avoir
assermentés leur nouveau gouvernement et
monsieur trudeau lui-même a été
questionné là dessus je voudrais le
lendemain de son élection et 10 offert à
prendre le temps de justement mettre sur
pied comme dont la cause de la
complexité parce qu'il faut enquêter sur
les ratés des enquêtes policières à
lescure mais aussi à la grc dans
plusieurs juridictions au pays ne peut
pas enquêter là dessus sans aussi
enquêter sur le fond de la problématique
pourquoi ces femmes là se retrouvent
dans des situations si vulnérable et
comment apporter des solutions
constructives
donc c'est très certainement ça va
donner tout un sens je voudrais au choix
du ministre des affaires autochtones et
des affaires indiennes
que fera justin trudeau lors de la
fermentation de son cabinet parce qu'un
dernier point là dessus emmanuelle et
sébastien vous rappelez vous un manuel à
la fin des années 90 il ya une
commission royale qui s'est penché sur
les autochtones au pays c'est si je les
avais monté sur le pupitre ici là il n'y
aurait que des des livres c'est énorme
le travail qui a été fait on se dit dans
la vraie vie quotidienne dans sur les
réserves par exemple n'a pas changé
grand chose donc la commission à québec
où si sébastien salois être seul
objectif de dire on veut pas juste
parler faut trouver des solutions
oui mais en même temps une commission
parlementaire est ce qu'elles trouvent
des solutions et fait des
recommandations et l'aide à mourir celle
des daoui rire se démener ce quelque
chose en effet mais la situation des
femmes autochtones ou la situation des
communautés autochtones entre vous et
moi on la connaît le nul à documenter
on sait que c'est terrible et que c'est
totalement dramatique alors il ya des
gens qui vous diront que c'est bien beau
de faire des commissions parlementaires
mais il faut passer à l'action il faut
régler ce problème chose est sûre c'est
une prise de conscience avec tout ce qui
se passe autour des communautés
autochtones paris-tokyo très bien manuel
comment se passe chez vous la transition
comment qu est ce que vous sentez ça
doit travailler francs pour le prochain
cabinet elle se passe tout en discrétion
patrice monsieur trudeau et pas dans
l'exercice de faire faire des grandes
séances de photo avec tous ses
conseillers qui pense au prochain
conseil des ministres
comme on a déjà vu dans le passé ce
qu'on lance ici
c'est un cercle assez restreint auquel
se greffent pour différentes raisons des
conseillers ce comité de transition il
est présidé par pires heures de
formation que vous connaissez que
monsieur tout le monde connaissent moins
bien si un ancien au mans darel du
gouvernement canadien était
sous-ministre conseil du trésor
industrie citoyenneté et immigration
affaires étrangères donc quelqu'un qui
connaît à la fois les rouages de la
machine gouvernementale canadienne mais
qui connaît également la nuance de
certains dossiers bouclés auxquels sera
confrontée justin trudeau et son
gouvernement seraient cette transition
elle a commencé avant lundi dernier dans
la fonction publique étaient prêtes les
cahiers de transition était prêt without
le processus qui est mise en branle
oui et ça et ce processus les électeurs
alignés amélie mis en branle depuis de
nombreux mois le but pour la fonction
publique c'est que peu importe qui était
élu le soir il y avait un cahier bleu un
cahier rouge un cahier orange pour
répondre à comment mettre en oeuvre les
promesses des différents partis on est
là dans la priorité si l'on de choisir
qui sera élu d'une certaine façon au
cénacle du conseil des ministres mais
surtout rédiger ce qu'on appelle les
lettres demande à sa part est très
optimiste et très important c'est le
mandat que donne le premier ministre à
ses ministres quelles sont ses priorités
à court moyen et long terme et donc on
est là dans et ceci sans compter
l'organisation du bureau du premier
ministre qui va occuper quel poste
comment est chez terra donc le temps
file parce que c'est le 4 novembre
prochain
très bien et on sera on sera ensemble
harry devra lui même est fort
intéressant de voir les choix qui ont
été faits s'est passé je peux vous
laisser partir pour la fin de semaine
avant de poser de questions hier
très rapidement on a glissé sur cette
fameuse prime de départ
parce que bon oui hier les gens ont
salué le départ de monsieur bédard tout
le monde a pu y avait pas d'anicroches
un pas que fonctionnel mais quand même
à chaque fois que quelqu'un part avant
la fin on le souligne depuis le début
hier c'est passé inaperçu ce que
monsieur drevet l'a fait une déclaration
là dessus me souviens de qu'on fait une
déclaration et pourtant stéphane bédard
est en totale contradiction avec la
position de bernard drainville
rappelez-vous bernard drainville au
pouvoir avait présenté un projet de loi
pour mettre fin à ses primes aussi les
allocations de transition
il a critiqué tous les libéraux qui sont
partis avec leurs allocations transition
en parlant de pas ouvert de buffet
chinois où les libéraux se servent comme
des ogres et la boum
stéphane bédard pas il prend son
allocation de transition 250 mille
dollars
l'ironie c'est que bernard drainville et
contre les allocations de transition il
a pris la place de stéphane bédard comme
dit aux parlementaires et stéphane
bédard lui fait peut-être un petit croc
en jambe en partant en prenant cette
allocation de transition
tuez 250 6351 mille dollars selon la
ligue des contribuables qui est toujours
de calculette pour faire ce genre de
calcul
alors on a ça pas été soulevée
énormément par les adversaires de
monsieur bédard
quoique il y en a qui vont soulever
quand même mais c'est peut-être parce
qu'on était sous le choc hier du départ
de stéphane bédard et que les gens
voulaient lui rendre hommage à la suite
de ces dix-sept ou dix-huit années
passées ici à l'assemblée
c'est tout juste s'il fallait quand même
quand le souligner parce qu'on l'a
beaucoup souligné rappelez vous convient
le souligner pour d'autres départs et
voilà emmanuel sébastien je le disais
chaque vendredi
vous êtes chef de bureau va essayer puis
des fois c'est des petites choses que
vous remarquez dans la semaine politique
on n'a pas le temps de le mettre dans
toutes les analyses ça sera la tribune
parfaite pour vous ici à 17h ce nouveau
rendez vous puis ça me fait plaisir
alors voilà rrpe bonne fin de semaine
parce que c'est bien mérité à emmanuel
bayle fait un salut au revoir au revoir